a nouméa les indépendantistes du fln ks
n'accepte pas la version officielle de
l'assaut donné par les forces de l'ordre
pour libérer les 23 gendarmes otages la
semaine dernière il affirme que le chef
du commando indépendantiste et 2 des
siens ont voulu se rendre et qu'ils ont
été abattus faut absolument faux répond
le général vidal qui commandait l'assaut
dans l'île d'ouvéa sur les lieux même de
la faire se sont déroulées aujourd'hui
les obsèques des 19 indépendantistes
tués lors de l'attaqué de la grotte où
ils séquestraient les gendarmes otages
et parallèlement sur cette terre encore
remarqué de violences avait lieu le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle françois corner au delà
des événements ces cercueils alignés
dans une fosse commune creusée dans le
corail au bord du pacifique marqueront
durant longtemps la conscience des
habitants des îles et de toute la
nouvelle calédonie stukus branche
amessan ouvéa le nom d'un atoll
paradisiaque avant ce matin là
aujourd'hui la communauté kanak est venu
voter dans la petite mairie jouxtant la
gendarmerie le meurtre des gendarmes
la prise d'otages la soupe pour la
grotte les 19 morts de l'île et ceux des
forces de l'ordre sont dans toutes les
consciences mais de devoir pour la
france sur cette île du bout de monde à
20000 km de la métropole a été accompli
par la quasi totalité des habitants à
100% cadac